russel de las artes
[Música]
maría carolina piña
un gusto saludarles nuevamente desde
parís y bienvenidos a este programa en
el que les traemos mucho sabor y color
pues recibimos al fenómeno de la música
funk afro caribeña sima font que está
hoy con nosotros muchísimas gracias cima
por estar aquí en carrusel de las artes
gracias a ustedes un gusto de gusto
estar aquí bueno directo de la habana a
parís para presentar un nuevo disco que
se llama el alimento así que vamos a
hablar ya mismo contigo de ese nuevo
trabajo discográfico sima font hoy en
carrusel de las artes
no lo sé
y para los que aún no lo conocen sima
font se hizo famoso con un disco que
causó sensación una canción que se llama
me voy y suena así
y
mi casa
[Música]
me voy
me voy a décima font y nosotros no nos
vamos nos quedamos con el sima y lo
primero que hay que decir es que si
masón que es la contracción décima de
cimarrón en recuerdo a los esclavos que
buscaban su libertad y de ese ritmo el
funk que es tu lenguaje pero un funk con
mucho ritmo caribeño si total total está
mezclado con mucha mucha música
afrocubana tiene todo lo que es pilón el
son un chachachá mambo tiene toda esa
mezcla suben sube sabrosa y ahora me voy
forma formó parte de un primer disco
terapia tú eras antes de ser músico
quería ser médico y bueno ese nombre de
terapia me imagino que viene por la
medicina pero cuéntanos cómo ha sido
este trabajo de implantar el funk en una
isla que tiene tanta tradición musical
como es que ha sido muy divertido sobre
todo porque de alguna manera no estaba
pasando así tan fuerte cuando empecé a
hacerlo en 2019 pero la gente lo tiene
interno porque estuviera que estuvo en
ese la banda en todas esas bandas
siempre han estado haciendo pong con
música afrocubana no de la manera que lo
hago yo pero eran los maestros y de
pronto cuando lo que la gente empezó a
entender lo empezó a descargar le empezó
a usarlo y fue divertido ver la reacción
y ahora mismo el mundo está súper
conectada con todo el font y todas las
aberturas y desde el principio fue un
éxito en cura en cuba fuera de cuba
también aquí la prensa
francesa se ha catalogado como el
tornado el huracán que viene de cuba
como has vivido tú es a ese éxito esa
fama con ese ritmo que tú has impuesto
en su país a estados ricos estaba rico
ha sido muy rico desde que es una suerte
que la gente ha empezado a consumir la
música y que se han empezado a encarnar
y que y que sobre todo lo que es lo más
rico de todo ha sido ver la reacción de
la gente en el live en vivo es a esa
sensación porque eso es lo que genera el
funk y la música afrocubana bailarle que
tener un estado tribal donde la gente
hace ripe hacer rompe todo el mundo goza
todo mundo sudado mundo se los veía bien
y ha sido muy rico ver eso y cada vez ve
como el número de personas aumenta y eso
se ve más grande y también colabora con
toda la gente que hemos logrado
colaborar como chicho de gómara punto de
aragón
pancho amat ha sido tremenda suerte
poder llegar a hacer cosas con ellos
todo el tiempo estaba generando
información y generando música no hemos
parado de crear canciones todo el tiempo
de tiempos de tiempo bueno en estos
cuatro años desde el 2017 2021 estás
sacando un nuevo disco que se llama el
alimento y hablabas de otros artistas
con el que estás los estás colaborando
entre ellos está chucho valdés cuéntanos
que trae ese alimento que traes de nuevo
si el alimento es un cambio del alimento
diferente es la primera cosa que aunque
no la produzco yo es producido pues ya
que es place un producto bien conocido y
tremenda persona también mi amigo y
gracias a poder habernos conectados las
gracias nos conectaba y haber detenido
esa cosa de esa basura mutua y el
sentido musical en común así logramos
hacer este disco donde estarán bien
huertas youtuber está george clinton
también está si lo green está lupe
fiasco estás aquí town está style hoy y
está en mí ya están los jóvenes ha sido
un disco es de tremenda locura mucha
locura porque la hemos hecho todo online
no nos hemos visto ya aquí en vivo nunca
haciendo el disco sol online pero de
tiempo las sesiones ha sido súper
divertida y si lo que reconocerá el
clinton logra conocer si los green
también y ahí está ahí lo también a
todas estas todo estos monstruos también
que se sumaron a colaborar en el disco
el alimento y por eso se llama el
alimento porque lo que me mantuvo
alimentando método esta pandemia y
justamente hablas de george clinton que
es el artífice del funk como lo trajiste
a tu proyecto caribeño yo no sé todo
esto es una locura yo soy fanático de
georges desde siempre desde el primer
momento que escuché fonca l y todo el
movimiento george clinton james brown
prince ohio player marvin gay todo ese
movimiento soy fan de eso pero yo es
como sabes como el arquitecto y de
pronto
de alguna manera logramos hacer que la
música le llegara y a él le gustó
visionado funky y iphone que ya los
funky soul station farc y dijo que si al
momento que escogemos un vuelo llegamos
ahí y nos metimos al estudio y desde a
que funda las experiencias más bonitas
que tenía hasta ahora haber compartido
con él tanto tiempo y grabando y después
que fuera a mis conciertos de envío se
subiera en los show y fuera formará
parte del tour
entonces fue ha sido mágico tenerlo
presente en la música y en mi vida
normal
bueno hablabas también de esos artistas
conocidísimos de tu país cubano está
chucho valdés has cantado con omara
portuondo hay una canción que es
fantástica en la que mezclas las
tradiciones la música tradicional cubana
con lo que tú haces el funk entonces
aparecen todos ellos aparece pancho amat
el gran instrumentista del 3 está la
orquesta aragón vamos a escuchar un
poquito de eso porque también estaba
chucho valdés que no
escucharlo
bueno
no
a bailar pegados
el mundo de ripio
[Música]
bueno lo escuchamos y estamos bailando
ya cuando uno escucha este esta música
uno siente el tributo que quieres hacer
a la herencia afro caribeñas a la a las
tradiciones negras de tu país si total
total es que eso es ya cuando empecé a
hacer esta música y me empecé con mi
proyecto así como la cosa personal
de crear música y empezar a darle a la
gente un concepto musical que tuviera
que ver conmigo lo primero que vino fue
este identidad sabes de afro caribeña y
toda la música que trajo áfrica a mi
país y todo lo que eso es lo que se
generó en todo el concepto de música
bailable y entonces ya me sentí siempre
súper identificada con eso y abad ya
raíz de eso entonces empecé a buscar y
haber y siempre y ahí me doy cuenta de
que de que los animales y los monstruos
están todavía con nosotros y siguen
haciendo música entonces fue como que
está escrito está disponible hacer una
nación con medios de creador de la timba
de humana la vida de buenavista
y fue como que si están aquí vamos él lo
falla momento dijeron sí y ahí y creamos
una amistad y de familia y de ha sido
tremenda suerte
es rico también para mí personalmente
porque me siento cada vez más
identificado con lo que soy y con quién
soy de dónde vengo y las raíces y eso es
como sabes un lugar confortable por
supuesto que es importante y bueno el
período de confinamiento que hemos
vivido todos a nivel mundial con la
epidemia del coronavirus también te
permitió no sólo conquistar los
escenarios que ya los tenías conquistado
sino también las redes sociales lanzando
un challenge bailable del que nos va a
hablar natale olivares que recibimos
ahora en el estudio un reto bailable que
lanzaste por redes sociales y que mucha
gente respondió respondió exactamente
llamaría carolina o la cima funk
respondió presente al mensaje que si me
a frank siempre ha dado como mensaje
alrededor del mundo y es que cantar y
bailar nos puede cambiar y fue con esa
canción
cumbre
[Música]
y
ahora baila
[Música]
el comprar esa canción lo siento no
podía venir y no hablar de esa canción
que fue la canción creo que eso con
compras con compras pero bueno fue un
álbum un disco evolutivo anterior pero
muy importante porque fue hecho durante
la pandemia fue como una bofetada de
aire fresco un remedio a la melancolía
remedio al encierro porque los
confinamientos en cuba y el resto del
mundo y fue un challenge organizado por
si matan con un verdadero jurado
etcétera todo el mundo respondió
presente los jóvenes las abuelas los
profesionales bailarines de verdad
bailarinas de mentiras profesionales de
la salud etcétera etcétera
respondió presente cómo fue esa idea y
cómo fue también esa bofetada para
ustedes porque realmente fue un éxito
mundial mundialmente mundial pues
riquísimo pues riquísimo
nosotros estamos ha sido muy en casa
trancado y ésta dice la canción y era
como que bueno vamos a estar esta
canción junto con otras canciones que
teníamos ahí que había hecho así a
tiempo pero bueno no sabíamos qué hacer
y entonces vimos vamos a usar este pero
la canción no era ésta era con
cumpleaños a aceptar con comprada que
ahora y en cuanto sale con comprar la
gente soy bióloga entonces fue cómo
llegar vamos a ser un challenge bailen
gocen y vamos a ver que ahora con
estudio la gente se conectó durísimo se
conectó durísimo fue un chal en claro en
las redes sociales para saber quién era
el más positivo quien daba más energía
etcétera etcétera y hablábamos de los
niños claro hasta hubo un papá noel un
santa claus
[Música]
fenomenal un bailarín fenomenal pero
también hubo una ganadora una tarde en
una ganadora una ganadora que se llama
rosita en fin no fueron 3
nieta la mamá y la abuela cierto la roja
estas niñas fueron la más loca y más
grande que el chalet se ganaron la
medalla de oro el premio final una
sonrisa un sabor fue realmente yo creo
que bueno eso con género como 10.000
vista instantánea en en
instagram y bueno ya es muy tarde porque
se cerró el el charles pero habrán
habrán otros sanos y eso es siempre que
la gente quiera de conectarse con las
canciones y bailar y eso bueno estamos
para eso
carolina la redacción se sumen también
que significó justamente reunir a varias
generaciones de cubanos y de personas a
través de tu música riquísimo porque al
final es como te das cuenta eso que la
música no tiene no tiene ni fronteras ni
tiene edades ni tiene colores ni tiene
ideologías no tiene nada la música eso
cuando te llega el groove que llega del
llamado del cruz
y eso lo siente la música está antes que
todo entonces de pronto a rosa ya sus
nietas ya su hija y de pronto de los
chamas en la habana y vice llaman en
rusia niños chiquitos en rusia que no
saben español y saben nada eso bailando
con compras que eran pocos saben qué
cosas significan con compras este será
como dueño sugerido súper río bueno y
nosotros te agradecemos por haber venido
hasta acá a hablar de tu música de
second compra del nuevo disco alimento y
justamente vamos a terminar este
programa agradeciéndote por haber venido
hasta acá y cómo vamos a poner un
poquito de sabor para terminar nuestro
programa el caramelo que es una de las
canciones de este disco alimento décima
foto muchísimas gracias por haber venido
gracias mata luchó y los dejamos a
ustedes gracias por su sintonía los
dejamos con el caramelo
yo no
[Aplausos]
pero no tengo ganas
se pone bonita los oigo control a los
mismos
pero con todo el vino se revienta las
cocheras de forma
avance
ah
[Aplausos]
pero para ti caramelo